[Música]
mas eu falar que fico preocupado por ter
me colocado como um dos últimos
palestrante porque todos são tão
motivadores e eu acredito que eu trago
perguntas um pouco perturbadores
é como o professor de direito mais um
filósofo frustrado eu queria muito ser
filósofo mas meu pai falou que eu tinha
que fazer alguma coisa que dava dinheiro
a cabeça do professor raimundo
não adiantou muito mas eu não abandonei
a filosofia
eu acredito que as perguntas ela são em
certa medida mais importante do que as
respostas
nós devemos fazer perguntas
interessantes porque são elas que nos
torna interessante que a filosofia
ela trata disso foi que ela trata da
organização daquelas perguntas muitas
vezes nós achamos que são todas porque o
céu é azul um dia meu filho me perguntou
o que eu tenho a dizer que o primeiro
impulso é um fato
depois coisa uma penca de provas ea
bíblia neto observá
de acordo com vai ficar a saber que
importa
e aí eu pensei em conta as pessoas me
ligaram perguntas e falei meu filho eu
ainda não sei mas eu vou tentar
descobrir pra você e vi nenê e vê nele o
prazer de ter aprendido o quilo
mas o que foi mais importante é que eu
percebi que eu pensava que aquela
pergunta toda e depois eu percebi que
ela só era toda porque eu tinha
banalizado porque a gente já dava
importância quanto conhecimento de
física
dentro de ótica tem embutido na resposta
para satisfazer a curiosidade de uma
criança
eu aprendi eu aprendi que não têm
perguntas banais e comecei a colocar
meus olhos de forma diferente sobre
algumas perguntas que eu achava banais
uma delas é aquilo que está naquela
música do gonzaguinha né ea vida que é
jogar lá é normal
[Música]
a vida é uma coisa que é a uma palavra a
gente usa certa forma é tão corriqueiro
muitas vezes até em viana
quem fala é o esporte a vida a
alimentação a vida mas é a gente não
respondeu à pergunta o que é riba
isso me lembra um pouco
santo agostinho santo agostinho foi
perguntado para ele certa vez é o que é
o tempo e ele falou assim ah se ninguém
me pergunta eu sei mas se eu quiser
explicar que ainda eu já não sei porque
para fazer um paralelo com a palavra de
dias com a vida
se alguém me pergunta o que quer vida eu
tenho é possível então me explica o que
é isso aí que você está me diga o que é
isso que você é
me diga lá é claro que a vida é agora
sim você perguntando assim de pronto e
com pouco complicado a vida a sete
o coração bater meu coração está batendo
isso ele é vida
não não não não é não é vida isso isso é
um sintoma de dólar
se o seu coração tiver bater é razoável
supor que há um indicativo que você deve
estar vivo até mesmo porque o programa
indicativo porque hoje está com o
coração batendo não é significado
suficiente para o diagnóstico final você
efetivamente está a ver com o veremos
daqui a pouco mas e o problema é que
muita gente acredita que pelo simples
fato da pessoa estar viva ela tem
autoridade para dizer o que é ser vivo e
ela não consegue perceber que a vida ela
não é só o fato biológico porque se você
reduz a vida um fato biológico você está
reduzindo o ser humano o fato biológico
e nós longe de sermos existentes em uma
única dimensão
nós somos seres multidimensionais nós só
os seres biológicos nós somos seres
econômicos nós somos seres culturais nós
somos seres afetivos nós somos seres
intelectuais ea nossa vida se desdobra
essas múltiplas dimensões e não seres
históricos a vida de um homem de render
o a vida de um homem de neandertal muito
provavelmente tem uma significação muito
diferente de um australopithecus e assim
sucessivamente quando conforme nós
caminhamos pelas paragens da evolução
não só modifica nosso corpo mas a nossa
vida e o valor que nós damos a vida como
se modifica
isso se torna
especialmente relevante porque a
radicalização das tecnologias elas
implicam e nem conhecimento extremamente
profundo do corpo humano de bola que
muitos gostam de comparar o corpo como
se fosse uma máquina
se eu conhecer o enquadramento e as
peças aquilo que compõem essa máquina eu
vou conseguir aperfeiçoar essa marca
se eu conseguir descobrir tudo aquele
misterioso que está no código genético
de uma pessoa eu poderei aperfeiçoar
essa pessoa eu vou poder criar um novo
ser humano
mas quais são as implicações da
tecnologia aplicadas à vida humana
eu tenho muito medo eu tenho muito medo
eu tenho muito medo porque as novas
tecnologias elas estão impactando de
forma tão intensa a nossa vida que nós
estamos modificando não só a forma que
nós a vemos mas também a forma com a
qual nós nos relacionamos com a vida dos
próximos daqueles que são estranhos que
eu não conheço
olha só quando nós temos a questão da
descoberta do dna e todas as questões de
seqüenciamento com a criação de novas
máquinas cada vez mais poderosas para
processamento de uma quantidade maciça
de dados
é impossível que nós tenhamos um ser
humano por design
cada vez mais eu posso por exemplo é
pensar que o futuro já como passado
muito do que as pessoas escreverão como
ficção científica hoje é verdade ou é
realidade população sofrendo as
conseqüências da infecção que tem uma em
transportar para simon
o futuro não é mais como era antigamente
como que nós vamos pegar e nossos
valores e como nós vamos responder a uma
sociedade que construir um novo ser
humano
aliás já foi muito preocupado se nós
podemos construir por design um ser
humano como tem muita gente que quer
escolher o sexo do bebê
tem muita gente que é escolher os olhos
do bebê já está existindo uma certa
perspectiva de escolher um dos três mas
é específico como inteligência
capacidade física altura
se eu tenho um ser humano construído por
design qualquer responsabilidade de quem
é a responsabilidade se dá alguma coisa
de errado com design
se tem um carro dirigido por um
computador e acontece um acidente
a responsabilidade do condutor
[Música]
o fabricante o programador se eu tenho
um ser humano construído por design e
ele vem defeituoso por exemplo com
agressividade desmedida de quem é a
responsabilidade se essa pessoa praticar
um crime é ele ou é do programador esse
ser humano por design e mais cheguei os
seres humanos por design o que vai
acontecer se ele ficar obsoleto
se nós não falamos de tecnologia que a
tecnologia ela vai ficando mais velha
cada vez mais rápido então não faço um
ser humano por design perfeito perfeito
para satisfazer todas as necessidades da
sociedade
só que a sociedade mudou amanhã eo
amanhã já é passado e essa pessoa eu
estou aqui nós vamos fazer com as
pessoas
parece que toda a gente fala de tornar o
ser humano ser
ou melhor parece que nós não estamos
falando de tornar um ser humano melhor
nós estamos querendo falar de tornado
mais útil
ensinar que utilidade é a métrica
adequada pra gente
medir o valor do ser humano o qual eu te
proponho a ideia do dilema de mefisto
imagine que bom
aparece o capeta que cascos chifre chope
que recebe e faz uma proposta de a bola
que ele falou olha olha só eu vou fazer
pra você uma oferta que você não pode
acusar eu vou agora eu vou curar o
câncer
ninguém vai morrer de câncer montoya
olha que maravilha na tabela taboca
pedra mas o que você quer em troca passa
você quebrar o pescoço desse bebê de
seis meses
do ponto de vista utilizar vocês
concordam que não tem muita dúvida basta
você matar uma pessoa e milhões de
pessoas terão a sua vida poupada
quanto sofrimento não deixará de existir
mas note que a vida humana ela não se
rege com esse valor matemático de
utilidade para a vida humana não pode
ser reduzido a um commodity porque se
fizéssemos isso reduzimos a vida humana
um commodity
nós nos tornaremos fungíveis significa
uma pessoa para salvar 100 milhões a
tudo bem está bom e segue para salvar
milhão
tá e que mil para salvar 100 mil a de
repente nós não percebemos que nós
sacrificamos o próprio valor da vida
humana
a ideia do sagrado nós não podemos
esquecer que apesar dessa questão do
design
apesar da genética e incluir
profundamente na própria idéia de
concepção de qual ser humano nasce hoje
hoje nós não podemos dizer daquele
ditado latino eu fiquei imaginando o
jurisconsulto de roma
existe um ditado que falava assim
matters e enter certa é este
a maternidade sempre acerta hoje não
hoje você fala na sede a barriga de
aluguel que é hoje você tem alguns casos
onde por exemplo um casal de mulheres
ele encontra um amigo pede uma doação de
esperma e no google o de uma determinada
das parceiras e se encontra à concepção
e coloca o óculo na barriga na terceira
pessoa
quem são os pais
quem são hoje em dia nem pra falar que a
mãe na maternidade é sempre certa a
genética mudou do uso e hoje nós
começamos a discutir quando que a vida a
gente pensa quente é nosso jeito de vida
época começa nem deus em várias teorias
sobre isso
só que o que é interessante é que cada
uma dessas teorias ela não nasceu de uma
percepção sobre o que acredita em si mas
ela nasceu de uma mudança tecnológica e
acabou determinando uma mudança de como
nós pensamos abertura da 11 chama a
atenção de vocês para
uma das grandes tecnologias que
aconteceu nos últimos 50 anos que mudou
e vai mudar muito a forma de pensar
o transplante de órgãos porque as
grandes jogos é uma coisa ficção
científica até que foi um cara lá e
conseguiu um transplante de coração
gente só tático antes do transplante de
coração a gente não tinha dúvida quando
com a sua avó parada cardiorrespiratória
irreversível depois que teve o
transplante de coração a gente fosse
agora tem outra é um problema que já
esperara parada cardiorrespiratória
irreversível não vai fazer transplante
porque o corpo ele entra naquela
entropia típica da morte
várias toxinas vão acabar tornando os
órgãos imprestáveis então é não dá
se a gente continuar com esse conceito
de morte a gente não vai conseguir fazer
transplantes de órgãos
que tal a gente fazer um novo conceito
de morte como falar então de morte
encefálica ou morte cerebral pronto
agora um assunto novo conselho de barba
rija
esse conceito de morte ele não surgiu
necessariamente necessariamente porque
ele é mais adequado
ele surgiu porque nós devemos
instrumentaliza a própria morte do
cantor na útil para a humanidade
olha só não só a vida tem que ser útil
mas a morte tem que ser útil também um
certo dia e isso eu ver isso eu vejo
como uma coisa extremamente problemática
veio uma questão problema por exemplo na
holanda holanda é um país extremamente
avançado na questão das discussões sobre
a eutanásia é eutanásia é pela primeira
vez na história é uma questão de saúde
público fala que tem que ser humano
severo demais ea gente perplexa seja não
viveu o suficiente eu acho que já está
na hora de você
esta é a melhor nas na holanda tem uma
política de eutanásia tão liberal tão
liberal que tem velhinho e do problema
ganha porque tem medo dos familiares
fazem o trabalho deles eu tenho
refugiados da morte por assim dizer e aí
você pergunta então se o valor da vida
não é utilidade
o que é bem eu acredito que nós devemos
voltar ao básico
eu acredito que a vida é um valor
sagrado mas num sentido religioso
todos os seres humanos eles são
absolutamente ou deveriam ser
absolutamente repetíveis são infundiu mc
por todos são ruins aqui ficava mais
nisso me parece que nada mais atual do
que aquele ensinamento milenar do
talmude quem mata uma visita a uma
unidade
quem salva uma vida salva a humanidade
nesses tempos de revolução tecnológica
não percamos a essência do que nos faz
humanos
vamos salvar o mundo uma vida de cada
vez
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]